the word nano really does again does
come from the great but the greek word
meaning dwarf as far as i understand
so what you're seeing here are
individual each blob each single blob
here is a single carbon atom
on a graphite surface so graphite is
pencil lead and
the business end of the microscope is
here so this tiny little thing which
doesn't cost that much
costs around four to five thousand
pounds something like that
allows us to see individual atoms and
indeed in the best circumstances allows
us to manipulate atoms and to move
structures around at the scale of
nanometers so in here we've got actually
quite a simple
instrument what it is is a sharp tip
brought very very close to a surface so
close actually within a nanometer or so
so that even though the two things
aren't touching due to some weird
quantum mechanics a weird effect called
tunneling electrons actually get across
the gap
oh
can i get a prop
church
fantastic
so you can do it in one of two modes you
can either hold the tip constant above
the surface and then just measure how
that current is changing it's called
constant height mode or alternatively
and how this is working what you do is
you tell the computer to keep the
current constant so to keep the current
constant what it has to do is follow
the trajectory of the pattern of atoms
on that that surface the topography of
the pattern of atoms on that surface
it's kind of like an old-fashioned
record player if people can remember
record players
where you had an arm and a needle
the only thing about this microscope is
that the arm is is is absolutely tiny
it's about a
fraction of a millimeter in length and
the little point is now basically got a
single atom on the end of it and so the
difficulty of course with constant
height mode where you just keep it like
that is it's fine if you've got a nice
flat surface if you haven't got a nice
flat surface
yeah let's say we've got a defect at the
surface something like this where the
surface isn't quite as flat as we'd like
what will happen of course is that the
tip will crash into that if you're not
continually adjusting the site that's
why this constant current mode is so
much better because as we move the tip
across it will detect oh hang on there's
a
bigger increase in current i must be
getting closer to the surface got to
pull back pull back maintain the current
constant and then continue on its way
okay so
nanoscience is not i would argue and i
think anybody who's a nanoscientist
would argue this as well is not this
wonderful new type of physics or new
type of science or
groundbreaking new paradigm it's not
like quantum mechanics it's not like
relativity but what it is is a natural
convergence of
physics chemistry biology engineering
all right down at the single atom at the
single molecule level
and so although nano of the over the
past decade or so has really exploded
into this wonderfully new as you say
buzzword it's
it's been around for a lot longer than
that really the
nano stems from the the word nanometer
and a nanometer is uh a billionth of a
meter
the question is well what does that mean
in sort of terms we can get to get our
heads around which is so more connected
to the real world so i guess many people
will have seen microscope images of red
blood cells for example and those are
off the order of 5 000 nanometers across
these
really neat movies videos you see of
bacteria multiplying so bacteria are
typically hundreds to thousands of
nanometers across so we're working on
length scales much much smaller than
than that sort of one of the molecules
that's custom built for nanoscience and
has has really been used by very many
groups in nanoscience to do a range of
remarkable things is c60 so c60 is
literally a molecular football
so you have um
[Music]
a structure that looks very much like
this this is a conventionally stitched
football so you can imagine taking this
and what you do is you take a carbon
atom put it there there there there
there all the vertices of these there
were 20 hexagons and 12 pentagons and
then if you imagine shrinking that all
the way down by um about a factor
of uh
let me see a hundred million then you
will end up with a c60
there are many ways to describe what a
nanometer is and many people talk about
it in terms of well what's the
relationship of a nanometer to the
diameter of a human hair my my favorite
one is the rate your hair grows so your
hair will grow about a nanometer a
second the one i really like is
something that's a definition that was
put forward by one of the people who
worked on c61 the phd students actually
if you take the earth
and shrink it down to the size of a
football if you then continue that
process again
what you get is a c60 molecule so the
size of a c60 is to a football as the
size of a football is to the size of the
earth so it gives you a nice some idea
of scale or you can think about another
one is if a seagull lands on a big
american aircraft carrier one of those
really big ones and a seagull lands on
it the aircraft carrier will sink by one
nanometer there's an extremely important
physicist called richard feynman from
the 20th century now dead but
really important made
contributions in a wide range of areas
and he said if there was one sentence
that you could use to uh to sort of
encompass all knowledge to uh known to
man you know if there's going to be a
great cataclysm there's going to be a
great
apocalypse um what would you what would
be that sentence of information would be
the shortest sentence that would contain
the most information and fineman's
argument feynman statement was
all matter is made of atoms small
particles that attract each other when
they're a certain distance apart and
then repel each other when they get
closer he said that that would hold the
most information he's
credited by many as being the forefather
of nanotechnology in that he gave a talk
way back in 1959 called there's plenty
of room at the bottom and it's almost
for bolton not to mention
feynman during a talk on journal
description of nanoscience because he
said
imagine if we could manipulate the atoms
all the way down all the way this was
all the way back in 1959 and he wasn't
to know at the time that really that
ability to see and manipulate individual
atoms was less than 30 years away and so
that's where we've ended up with today